[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: We present to
you the final Decoding
Race talk back here at
my home, New York City,
and I will now introduce
Roland Martin who
has been an amazing friend
to me for more than 10 years.
He's an award-winning
journalist,
an all-around amazing
television-radio personality.
He's the current host of
"NewsOne Now" of TV One
and just fantastic.
He was the first moderator
for Decoding Race,
and he's going to give
us a grand closing.
So join us, Roland.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
ROLAND MARTIN: All right, folks.
What's up?
I'm on?
I'm on now?
All right, cool.
So how are we doing?
OK.
I break rules.
I'm not going to
be sitting down.
So let me move this over here.
All right.
So everybody's good?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: All right, then.
So they gave me a list
of questions to ask.
I don't know why they did that.
So whoever stayed up to
write those questions,
cut somebody out, because
I'm not going to read them.
You wasted your time.
We're going to have
a great conversation.
So I'm going to bring up
our panelists right now.
So let's get this thing going.
So you all are
like, he really did
say he was going to do that.
I tell you.
Luvvie, come on out, Luvvie.
Thank you for dressing
up for the panel.
[APPLAUSE]
Appreciate that.
We appreciate that.
Yes.
Looking mighty
dressy, of course.
"New York Times" best
selling author, speaker,
digital strategies.
Of course, she deals at
the intersection of comedy,
technology, and activism.
Of course, we just
call her Luvvie.
You got a last name?
Are you like Cher or Madonna?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Ajayi.
ROLAND MARTIN: OK.
Gotcha.
All right.
Cool.
Just checking.
All right.
Give it up for Luvvie Ajayi.
[APPLAUSE]
Vint Cerf.
Vint, where are you, Vint?
Come on up.
VINT CERF: I'm right here.
ROLAND MARTIN: He
dressed the hell up.
[APPLAUSE]
Vint with a three-piece.
All right.
Vice President, Chief Internet
Evangelist for Google.
Of course, contributes to
global policy development
and continued spread of
the internet as well.
Give it up for Vint.
[APPLAUSE]
VINT CERF: Thank you.
ROLAND MARTIN: Paola Mendoza,
the Chief Co-director
of Partnerships and Artistic
Director for the Women's March
in Washington.
She's done documentaries
like "Free Like the Birds,"
"Autumn's Eyes," "La
Toma," "Still Standing."
Wow, that's mighty
environmental of you.
"Free Like the Birds,"
"Autumn's Eyes," What's next?
Winter Solstice?
PAOLA MENDOZA: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: All right, cool.
All right.
So give it up for Paola, please.
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
Where's Eddie Huang?
Eddie, where are you?
Eddie, come on up.
All in the back, hanging out.
He's a lawyer turned clothing
designer, restaurateur,
TV host, and author.
[APPLAUSE]
Guess you were bored
with the law, huh?
EDDIE HUANG: How are you?
ROLAND MARTIN: So of course,
he has a restaurant in New York
City's East Village.
He also is the author
of the "New York Times"
best selling memoir "Fresh
Off the Boat" and host
of his own show on Viceland.
That's our panel.
[APPLAUSE]
So anytime we have
these conversations,
folks always it's a
conversation about race.
And I never understood what--
I don't see what people
really mean by that.
And so anybody can jump in.
I'm not going to direct
it to anybody at all.
What should folks get
out of these discussions,
out of these conversations?
What should they get?
Don't need raise your hand.
VINT CERF: First thing I would
say is that what you want
is to get comfortable
with candor.
That's probably the
most valuable lesson
that you could
possibly take away
is it's OK to have candid
discussions about hard topics,
not only here in Google
but outside as well.
EDDIE HUANG: I think it's
important with race discussion
to acknowledge that
it's a social construct.
Do you know what I mean?
Like race is a social
construct, and I
think an excellent starting
point for any conversation
about race is to acknowledge
that it's a social construct,
that we carry pretty much the
same genetic DNA amongst all
of us and that a lot of the
things people have told us
about race are
entirely fabricated.
VINT CERF: That's fair.
LUVVIE AJAYI: So
social constructs
are sometimes we want to use as
an excuse to not give something
the weight that it should have.
Money is also a
social construct.
Language is a social construct.
But it's as real as the
fact that the sky is blue,
because how we
behave around race
means that social construct
has real-life consequences.
So I don't want people to be
thinking, just because it's
social in that we just created
it, we created most things.
This chair, Christmas, but
we give each other gifts.
Like, Santa is not real.
VINT CERF: He's not?
EDDIE HUANG: But the
thing is with race
is that so many people have
been promoting or perpetuating
the idea that there is some
genetic foundation to race.
I'm sure you remember that
"Sports Illustrated" article
from 25 years ago saying
that black athletes had
a different ligament or
a different hamstring
and trying to give credence to
race with a genetic foundation.
And I think it's important
to kind of dispel
a lot of those myths when
having those conversations.
It's a starting point.
Of course, social
constructs have
the value that you give it.
Do you feel like
at times with race
that people have tried to create
a narrative that it's destiny
or that sometimes the way
people act is predetermined
by the universe
or somebody else.
PAOLA MENDOZA: I think
also with regards
to what people should be
talking about with regards
to race today, I want people
to recognize where we are
politically in this country
today is, in my mind,
because of our lack of
ability to speak about race,
to see where the president
is and the policies that he's
implementing now, in my mind,
are surrounded and based
in the idea of white supremacy.
And even that word, when
you start saying that word,
people get very uncomfortable.
And I think, as you
were saying, that we
have to lean into that quote,
unquote "uncomfortability,"
those courageous discussions,
those daring discussions
to move forward in
order to get to a more
honest and sincere place.
ROLAND MARTIN: When we
talk about this issue,
I think for so many
people, they're
wholly ignorant of
American history.
And so that's also
part of the problem.
When you begin to confront
the issue of race,
and you begin to understand
economically, understand
socially and culturally, as
you begin to talk to folks,
you start throwing out
things that happened.
And two years from now
we'll be commemorating
the 400th anniversary of the
first folks of African descent
to come to the United
States in 1619.
You explain to people
244 years of slavery,
almost 100 years of Jim Crow,
even mention reconstruction.
And I'm not talking about the
low-information Trump voters.
I was in an event after
the election in DC.
So all these really
smart people there,
probably about five
black people in the room,
about four Latinos in the room.
I think there were
a couple Asian.
Everybody else was white.
And I asked the
question, how many of you
know about reconstruction?
Literally three hands went up.
Three.
VINT CERF: Doesn't that happen
after surgery or something?
ROLAND MARTIN: Huh?
VINT CERF: Sorry.
ROLAND MARTIN: They
all had lobotomies.
I don't know what was going on.
And so even when I threw out the
question of same-sex marriage,
Equal Protection
Clause, 14th Amendment,
I'm like, that was a
reconstruction amendment.
They had no idea.
And so when you try to even
have a conversation as to how
we got to this point and folks
have no idea about history,
I think that also is a
contributing factor as to why
people are so scared
because, frankly, they
don't know jack even with
their wonderful degrees.
VINT CERF: So can I just
make an observation?
It's something that you said
I think is very important.
It's this social construct
notion applies not only
to race, but it applies to all
kinds of different groupings.
You can group people
by all kinds of--
I'm the token old fart,
for example, up here.
So the point I want to
make is the same tensions
can arise out of various
groupings, not just about race.
The value of having the racial
discussion, today anyway,
is that it will apply to all
those other groupings as well.
So there is a depth
of knowledge which
is missing, not only about
factual history with regard
to race but about other
to other groupings, whether
it's economic or, in my case,
I'm hearing impaired,
for example,
and so I fall into
a minority category
in that particular grouping.
So anyway, I just
think that the lessons
that we can learn from
these conversations
are broadly applicable to a
wide range of different kinds
of prejudice.
ROLAND MARTIN: One reason why
I think this is important is
because-- and I've been
saying this since 2009--
that we are about to embark
on what I call a 30-year war.
VINT CERF: Holy moly.
ROLAND MARTIN: And it's real.
Not the next election for
30 years, because by 2044
no one group will be
the dominant majority
in this country.
And once you start peeling back
the layers of why people feel
the way they feel today,
you cannot help but get
to the defining issue of race.
I'll throw this out to you.
So when the study was done last
year, the question was asked,
are you optimistic
about the future
of America for the next
10 years economically?
African-Americans,
lowest wealth in America,
highest optimism 58%.
Latinos, second lowest wealth,
second highest optimism.
VINT CERF: Interesting.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Whites in America,
highest wealth, lowest optimism.
LUVVIE AJAYI: That's
because they know
they're losing their power.
So it makes sense.
When you are the
person at the top,
you're the person that
everyone's gunning for.
So you know you have
nowhere to go but down.
I'd be sad too.
But it's about time.
That makes perfect sense.
We have higher optimism because
we're like, we can only go up.
VINT CERF: It can't
get any worse, right?
LUVVIE AJAYI: It
can't get any worse,
so I'm like I have nothing
but good things coming,
because if it got any worse,
jeez, I'd just not be here.
ROLAND MARTIN:
But the reason I'm
putting that out
there, because whenever
there are these discussions on
television, radio, in print,
they literally skip
right over that
and don't then ask a
second question, why?
Because now the
why question then
informs where we stand today.
The reaction to Trump
running, the reaction
to other candidates, what
buttons are being pushed.
And so when the immigration
button is being pushed,
they're really pushing
a different button.
When you have the whole
issue of globalism.
That's another
button being pushed.
No one talks about how
technology has changed the game
or how automation has wiped out
significant numbers of jobs.
Oh, no no.
Send those folks back to Mexico.
That's why we don't
have our jobs.
Those are buttons being pushed.
I just think that we have
to go much deeper when
we start talking
about why people
are responding the way
they respond politically.
EDDIE HUANG: And
also immigration
is a boon to the economy.
It always has, if you
study immigration patterns.
Even Buffalo, New York did not
have an increase in population
since I believe the 1950s.
In the last few years,
it has the most--
it's like the fourth largest
growing city in America
is Buffalo, New York.
And a lot of it is
immigrants coming
from Africa and the Middle
East, creating businesses.
You look at--
I believe it's
Deerfield, Michigan--
it's a very strong
Middle Eastern community.
Immigrants coming America,
they create businesses,
they become customers,
they become landowners.
And it's a boon to the country.
ROLAND MARTIN: But the
history, though, shows those.
When you have
economic anxieties,
there always is a tendency
I need to blame somebody.
EDDIE HUANG: And that's
a social construct.
That is a narrative
that white people
who are afraid of the
dispossession of their country,
they create that narrative
that it's Mexicans taking jobs.
It's immigrants taking jobs.
Immigrants fill jobs that normal
second and third-generation
Americans, they
don't want to take.
They don't need to take.
This is the new
workforce coming in,
whether it's building the
railroads, reconstruction,
the Panama Canal, the gold rush.
It was always immigrants coming
in and filling these jobs.
VINT CERF: So could I just
make an observation about this?
This entire country is
nothing but immigrants.
ROLAND MARTIN: Vint, you're
on the panel for observation.
You don't have to tell me.
You're saying you want
to make an observation.
EDDIE HUANG: I agree with you.
ROLAND MARTIN: Go ahead.
Go ahead.
VINT CERF: No, no.
I just wanted to make
that observation,
that this entire country
is nothing but immigrants.
That's where we all came from.
In fact, we displaced the
folks who were here before,
which is another big issue.
EDDIE HUANG: Before they were
Mexicans, before there was--
PAOLA MENDOZA: The Irish,
before it was Chinese,
before it was Japanese.
EDDIE HUANG: Italian,
Irish, or Jewish people
were treated the
way that a lot of us
are treated now,
maybe not as badly.
But like there was
always another.
There was always a
new immigration group.
There was always another.
PAOLA MENDOZA: So the reality
is, just off that point,
I think that from the
2008 economic collapse,
cities that had the
most immigration
population were the ones
that actually responded--
rebounded economically
better than other cities.
And our reality here
is, where we are today,
is to be an immigrant--
the existence
of an immigrant really at this
moment in time is to resist.
My existence as an immigrant
born in Colombia, here
in the United States for
the majority of my life
is one of resistance
because, again,
the political structure,
power structure, power vacuum
that we're in.
And on top of that, the idea
of undocumented immigrants
is even--
we see what was going on
yesterday in Texas with SB4
and the protests that
were there and that there
were actual fights between state
representatives on the floor,
and they were threatening--
one was threatening
to shoot another one.
He said that he called
ICE on protesters.
And so that is the political
climate where we are.
And I truly believe
that we're there
because actually we are
unable to communicate
with one another.
We are unable to reach
across the aisle, whatever
that aisle is, and see what
is happening with someone
that thinks differently.
Now, having a conversation
obviously is not--
I'm not saying to
have a conversation
is allowing for oppression
and for oppressive thoughts
to be legitimized but to
actually just sit down
with someone and say let's
break down the facts.
Let's break down the
history of this country
and talk about immigration
and talk about race
and see where we are and
see where we've been.
And so where are we
going to go and how are
we going to break the cycle?
But we're not doing
that at this moment.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Except when you're
defining things by fake news.
But you mentioned something
there when you said resist.
So the question I have--
OK, resist is one thing,
to get what is another.
So I can look at Montgomery
Improvement Association taking
place December 1st after
Emmett Till is killed.
And then I see this move in
the Black Freedom Movement,
this quest for freedom.
But resist is one thing.
To get what?
See because that's vital.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: You can resist,
then it's OK I've resisted.
But what the hell am I trying
to get with my resistance?
EDDIE HUANG: You know
I had a women's studies
professor in college break it
down for me, Dr. [INAUDIBLE]..
She said, you know, what
I want in this world is
the same opportunity for the
same job for the same pay
for the same work.
And I was like, that
makes some sense.
And in terms of
resistance, the thing
I always think
about resisting is
Americans have to resist this
idea that the country belongs
to one dominant cultural group.
It doesn't belong to one
dominant cultural group.
The country belongs to
this idea that there
can be a land in
this world founded
on equality, freedom
of expression,
and multiculturalism.
ROLAND MARTIN: But
stop right there.
EDDIE HUANG: That
is the idea that--
ROLAND MARTIN: I got
something right there, though.
You said a nation
founded on equality.
LUVVIE AJAYI: The idea.
EDDIE HUANG: The idea.
ROLAND MARTIN: But-- no, no.
PAOLA MENDOZA: But what?
ROLAND MARTIN: But even
that idea was a lie.
PAOLA MENDOZA: It wasn't, yeah.
ROLAND MARTIN: Because if you
are not a white male landowner,
the country was not
founded for you.
EDDIE HUANG: That's why I
say it's an idea, not a fact.
You know what I mean?
It's been sold around
the world as this idea.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Right.
EDDIE HUANG: But that's
our cultural soft powers
that we've exported this idea.
VINT CERF: Actually, it's
an aspiration and which
it involved--
EDDIE HUANG: It's a lifestyle.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I
don't even think--
that's the thing, though.
I don't even think America
aspires for equality.
That's the thing.
This country plays the
global captain save a planet,
like runs through and be like
there's no democracy here.
We're going to bomb your place.
Meanwhile, in our own country,
what happens, I think America--
back to one of your points--
one of the reasons why
we can't move forward
is because America
does not do a good job
of looking at itself in the
mirror and being like, oh, OK.
I see what's coming back at me.
It's playing this global leader
has this very high moral stance
elsewhere.
But what's happening
in the country
is just not-- it's the
same things we're bombing
people for is happening here.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Well, you're right.
I think if you read Stephen
Kinzer's book, "Overthrow,"
if you want to look
at what Russia did
to us in the last election--
PAOLA MENDOZA: Right.
You've done.
ROLAND MARTIN: Hell,
we did that going back
to [INAUDIBLE] in Iran in 1954.
PAOLA MENDOZA: We did
that to all Latin America.
ROLAND MARTIN: We pretty
perfected the art of jacking up
a country--
PAOLA MENDOZA: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN:
--with that group.
No, seriously.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Fact.
It's true.
Fact.
ROLAND MARTIN: But the reason I
want to stay on this whole idea
in terms of this
ideal, because as we're
talking about moving
discussions forward, trying
to figure it out, I think
we have to deal with that.
Because if you look
at income inequality
now, if you look
at how much wealth
is being held in
so few hands, it
is literally a 21st
century version
of when this
country was created.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Yeah.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
ROLAND MARTIN: You're literally
in the exact same spot in terms
of a handful of
people with wealth
determining the future
direction of the country.
And so I go back to
this notion of resist.
We are resisting to do what?
VINT CERF: Well, presume--
ROLAND MARTIN: To get what?
VINT CERF: Presumably more
equal treatment for everyone.
More equal opportunity
for everyone.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Yeah.
I think we're resisting
for two things.
In this immediate
moment, we're resisting
to protect our communities,
and all of our communities
are under attack
in various forms.
And then I would
also say that we
are resisting for freedom,
like we're resisting
for freedom of everything.
And it's something
to strive for.
Will we get there?
Not in my lifetime.
I don't know when
we'll get there.
LUVVIE AJAYI: [INAUDIBLE]
PAOLA MENDOZA: I know, right?
Sorry to break it to you.
EDDIE HUANG: I
think it's the two
things is that equal protection
of the laws that has never
been present.
And then the equal opportunity,
because I don't think anybody
here or listening or on
the stage wants anything
given to them.
I just want the
same opportunity.
ROLAND MARTIN: Like James
Brown said, open the door.
I'll get it myself.
LUVVIE AJAYI: You know--
PAOLA MENDOZA: Exactly.
LUVVIE AJAYI: You know, I would
want something given to me.
Yes.
Because this country
has been people of color
who have been
doing all the work.
So things have been
given to white people.
It's time for us to be
given some things too.
And I think the lack of--
the guilt that comes with us, we
work so hard that sometimes we
do get something given to us,
we're like did I deserve it?
Yes.
They've been getting this
for free for 400 years.
It's time for us to get some
things for free too and not
feel the guilt.
ROLAND MARTIN: I'll
go back to equality
and equal-- equal
protection, equal protection
clause, equality.
A lot of people love
Dr. King and one
of the things they don't realize
is that he rarely ever used
the word equality.
VINT CERF: That's interesting.
ROLAND MARTIN: He
typically said freedom.
He wanted freedom.
You said that earlier and that
is the moment a child is born,
even before that, you
want the mother to have
the same prenatal
care as somebody else.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Yeah.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
ROLAND MARTIN: But you
want freedom, freedom
to drive down the street
and not get pulled over,
freedom to not have somebody
call ICE because you
look Latino and they
think you're also
an illegal immigrant.
That to me, I , think,
as we're moving forward,
I look at word usage.
I think that's a more
powerful word, because when
you hear the so-called patriots,
oh, the founding fathers, they
believed in freedom.
See, I don't want equality.
Equality means you've
got to pass another law
to give it to me.
No.
I want what you've
got without a law.
That's freedom.
VINT CERF: So could I
make a suggestion to you?
When we look at
the Constitution,
and we look at the
Bill of Rights,
and you see the First Amendment
that speaks about freedom
of expression,
freedom to assemble,
freedom of [INAUDIBLE]--
ROLAND MARTIN: Not equality
of expression, freedom.
VINT CERF: No, no.
Yes.
I agree with you.
But I wanted to
emphasize something
that you didn't mention.
And that's another
notion of freedom
from harm, which is not
in our Bill of Rights
but it should be.
That's the one thing that
we are willing to give up
a certain amount of freedom
in exchange for safety.
And that's part of
the social contract.
It's a very tricky
concept, but it's one
that we have to embrace
because without that--
in theory, my freedom of
action should stop about 1 cm
from your nose.
ROLAND MARTIN: Actually it
should stop in that chair.
[LAUGHTER]
That's where it should stop.
You get your ass out that chair,
it's going to be a problem.
EDDIE HUANG: That's actually
the more conservative
interpretation of Locke.
He has the more liberal
interpretation of Locke
in the social contract,
which is that it's
up to the centimeter
of your nose.
It's that you can express
your freedom to the extent
that it does not impose
on someone else's
unlimited freedom.
And so I think as a
society it's like boxing.
It's about mastering
your distance.
ROLAND MARTIN: So
I'll throw this out.
So here we have
massive changes when
I look at what young
folks are doing today,
which is not unlike any
other areas of history.
I can think back to SNCC--
Student Nonviolent
Coordinating Committee--
1960s, meeting at Shaw
University and what they did
and how they drove the
Black Freedom Movement.
VINT CERF: SDS.
ROLAND MARTIN: But here's
what's very interesting to me,
is that when you begin to look
at polling data, when you look
at white millennials
who believe today
that racism against whites is
just as significant as it is
against African-Americans--
to your point
about it being a construct--
we have, I believe,
sold ourselves this
false notion that, oh,
but kids they all
listen to hip hop.
It's all good.
LUVVIE AJAYI: It's the
least racist generation.
ROLAND MARTIN: You find
that hilarious, I can tell.
EDDIE HUANG: I find it hilarious
because I remember growing up,
I actually felt a
lot of solidarity.
I found a lot of connectivity
to hip hop music.
It was the music that made me
feel less alone and less alien
because I was the only
Chinese kid in school.
But I knew that a
lot of the other kids
listening to it, that
it was a phase for them.
It was a costume, like
they come back from summer
and it's like, oh, I'm wearing
FUBU and Phat Farm now,
but then I knew next summer
they'd be wearing Abercrombie
& Fitch, you know?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yeah.
EDDIE HUANG: And by the
time people went to college,
they just dropped it.
A lot of people dropped it.
But then hip hop became
a mainstream culture.
But I think that says
more about this art form
that black communities
created, the power of hip hop
and how undeniable it is.
It's the most powerful
movement of the last 30 years.
ROLAND MARTIN: What
I'm trying to say
is that we can't
live on this idea
that just because there are
folks today who are 24, 25, 26,
that somehow everything
is going to change
because they live in a
much more diverse world
than their parents.
We actually still
take on the identity
and the views of our parents.
How--
EDDIE HUANG: It
becomes more insidious
when you don't think
there is an actual threat.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Right.
EDDIE HUANG: Right?
And so I think the ABC show,
that "Fresh Off The Boat"
is a real good example of
they'll use your yellow faces
and tell white stories.
You know?
ROLAND MARTIN: So
moving forward,
how do we be mindful
of that to ensure
we don't fall into the
trap of just assuming,
oh, it's all good?
EDDIE HUANG: I'm probably
the wrong person to ask.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Well,
we shouldn't assume.
So part of the
thing is we always
assume people are at the same
place we are in understanding,
in knowledge and
wherever our beliefs are.
And that's completely wrong.
Everyone got shocked
November 9 being
like, oh god, I thought
everybody I knew
was voting this way.
No.
That assumption
is wrong, which is
why the conversation
needs to happen in rooms
that are difficult or not.
We need to talk about white
privilege and the fact
that most people don't even
know what white privilege means.
They just think it
means that I got things
handed to me all my life.
These kids who are 24, 25
still doing blackface parties.
And then we want to
sit and be like they're
the least racist generation.
No, they're not.
They're being raised
by racists, so they're
going to be racist too.
It doesn't matter if they're
around black people all day.
If their mom and your dad
has beaten in your head
that this is exactly how--
white supremacy and the idea
of genetic supremacy.
And that is going to be
what they carry with them.
So we have to bring it to them.
ROLAND MARTIN: Does it
behoove us to quickly call
someone or something racist?
Here's is why I'm putting that
out there-- before you answer--
so here's what happens.
We have these
conversations today.
An event happens,
let's say blackface.
All of a sudden it
goes, that's racist.
No, it's not.
The conversation then is
no longer about blackface.
The conversation is now you're
racist, you're not a racist.
EDDIE HUANG: Yeah,
self-preservation.
ROLAND MARTIN: The
argument that I
make is there is a whole lot
of stuff in between racist
and non-racist.
I've rarely called
someone a racist,
because I want to stay focused
on exactly what happened
as opposed to that conversation,
because it will quickly shift.
EDDIE HUANG: Yeah.
For me, if I'm talking
to somebody about race
or I feel like maybe
something is racist,
I try to establish with
them in the conversation,
I don't want anything from you.
I want this for you.
Do you know what I mean?
I want you to have
this understanding
so everything I'm telling you
is not for me to report you
or to complain about
you or ruin your career.
I'm here for you to get
closer to the truth.
You know what I mean?
ROLAND MARTIN: Paola,
I'm going to go to you.
So for instance, same
thing happened when
it came to the Women's March.
I've been highly critical of the
National Organization for Women
for a long time because it
should have been the National
Organization for White Women.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Agreed.
ROLAND MARTIN: So when a
14-year-old girl in McKinney
had her face slammed into
the ground, now said nothing.
And I put them on blast and
ever since then, every time
something happens
with a black girl,
they put that statement
out in about 20 minutes.
But the point being, if you
say it now you're racist,
the reaction from these
white liberal women,
oh my god, I'm not racist?
No, but you're silent.
MENDOZA: Yeah.
So this is exactly what I
was going to talk about,
is the idea and the power of
language or lack of language.
So I work in the immigration
space, specifically
in the undocumented space,
and this is a new territory
for most people.
So people don't necessarily
know the language.
So you will hear
people say "illegal"
as opposed to "undocumented."
And I've kind of
perfected the way
in which to correct someone in a
non-confrontational, productive
way so that they actually
understand why they shouldn't
use that language.
I don't call people out
publicly, or if I do,
it's a very safe space
in which to do it in.
And I think that goes
to your question,
because at the end
of the day, what's
important to me in that
circumstance in particular
is to educate, empower,
and create a conversation.
And when we are attacking
people right away,
then that ability to have a
conversation is unattainable.
But also keeping in mind that
there are just some people
that I will not engage
in conversation with,
and those are just
the outliers that we
don't talk to or engage with.
And with regards to
the Women's March,
I think one of the
things that we're
most proud of is that we were
able to push the needle forward
within the women's
movement to talk
about this idea of feminism
being for white women
and really having white
women in particular
understand why feminism had
become so selectively white.
And within the organization,
we had numerous conversations
where we were crying,
upset, laughing.
And these were strangers.
These were 25
women, 30 women that
came together, didn't
really know one another,
to have these discussions.
And the people that were really
having the most emotionally
difficult discussions
were the white women
because they were being
confronted in a space where
they were actually equal
in numbers of women
of color and white women.
They were not the majority.
And so I always--
ROLAND MARTIN: And they
thought everything was good.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Oh, yeah.
They did know.
They honestly didn't know.
And so you don't know
what you don't know.
So that's where you
start the conversation.
And it's exhausting and tiring
and emotionally draining,
but it's one conversation
that each individual can
choose to take on.
So my point is that
again, it goes back
to this idea of conversations,
of how do you call someone
out in a way that's
productive and where
they don't get defensive.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Call in.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Exactly.
You call them in.
ROLAND MARTIN: Let
me do this here.
So how many folks in the
room have heard of Title IX?
VINT CERF: Oh yeah.
ROLAND MARTIN: How
many of you believe
that Title IX was about sports?
VINT CERF: No.
It was about gender.
ROLAND MARTIN: No, no.
It was about-- the way that
it's been positioned that it's
about sports and gender.
But if you actually
go back, Title IX
was created to
specifically open up
the professional schools
for women, doctors, lawyers,
dentists.
Now let me ask this question.
Who knows where Title
IX even comes from?
Precisely.
The 1964 Civil Rights Act.
So Title IX gets passed, '72.
Gets passed.
You see an explosion of women
become doctors, dentists,
lawyers, engineers, in
professional schools.
Largely white women, because
still the opportunities
were being closed
for black women.
So all these women--
talking about a lot
of women in the room--
who then go into
corporate America,
who get all these
particular jobs.
Guess what?
They were able to advance
because black folks marched
to get the '64 Civil
Rights Act passed.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Exactly.
ROLAND MARTIN: Now when
you throw that out,
and I've done this in speeches,
white women in the room
look at me like,
oh, my god, what
the hell is he talking about?
To Eddie's point, you're
talking about if you
are Chinese or
Korean or Japanese
and you appreciate voting
with your native tongue
in the ballot,
thank black people
and the 1965 Voting Rights Act.
I go back to the reconstruction
amendment, the Equal Protection
Clause, 14th Amendment,
that came out after slavery.
The point I'm making is--
also if you're disabled.
Remember the disabilities act?
Provision of the '64
Civil Rights Act.
All of these laws
that have been changed
were a result of the
black freedom movement.
And when you throw
that out there,
people then go, oh,
where you going?
Which allows me to go
into the next part.
That is when you look at
Black Lives Matter and then
these efforts that
are happening today,
these laws that are being--
these changes are being forced
not to just benefit black folks,
but again, like everything else
that I just said, to benefit
every other American.
How do we get that
through folks' heads
that it just ain't
a black thing?
A body camera can
save your ass, too.
VINT CERF: Good point.
EDDIE HUANG: As a kid, like, I
didn't see Asian politicians.
I didn't see that
many Asian leaders.
There was not any
representation of us
culturally besides Bruce Lee.
You know?
And I read Hank
Aaron's autobiography.
I would read "Thank
You, Jackie Robinson."
I listened to Charles Barkley.
You know, like, as much he
didn't want to be a role model,
he was my role model, you know?
And I read about the march.
I read about Malcolm
X, Martin Luther King.
And I read, "I Have A Dream"
and compared it to "Letter
From Birmingham Jail."
And I started to realize--
I was like, black people
have paved the way for anyone
of difference in America.
And I think for me, I grew up
just always wanting solidarity,
because I could see
strength in solidarity
and I could see how
I was benefiting
from the work of
black Americans.
And going to the Women's March--
you know, I went to
the Women's March.
It was one of the most
incredible things I've seen.
And once I saw Trump
going at women,
I was like, we're actually going
to make some progress here,
because everybody has a mother.
Everybody has been kind of
slandered by this man now.
And this is now
everybody's fight
and everybody has to join in.
ROLAND MARTIN: Yes.
EDDIE HUANG: And then--
I'm sorry.
I haven't finished the point.
Then the Women's March became
this platform and this canvas
that everyone could bring their
issues and their stories to.
And I saw tons of
Black Lives posters.
And you know, it
was a place where
everyone had a place
to come have a voice
and stand up for something.
And the women at
the march really, I
think, carried the
torch and carried
a lot of people's issues
for them that day.
ROLAND MARTIN: Yet 53% of
white women voted for Trump.
Yet people then, after
the election, said whoa,
I was voting for this,
I totally ignored this.
Like all the people right
now who are now crying,
please don't take
my health care.
Now you're trying to wake up.
So as we're moving forward, all
these different movements that
are going on--
EDDIE HUANG: I'll
take them whenever
they want to wake up, though.
You know what I mean?
LUVVIE AJAYI: I sat
out the Women's March,
and it was a persons
decision to do that.
Because I was like,
you know what?
Yes, black people are
always showing up.
Honestly, on this
day, I don't want to.
So I actually sat
home, and I didn't go.
But I was like, props
to everybody who went,
and I really respected the
significance of the event
and how massive it was.
I mean, biggest protest ever.
OK, so that was epic.
But the fatigue that comes
from always showing up
for people who never show
up for you, on that day,
I was not feeling the need
to be uniting with anybody.
I was like, I
[INAUDIBLE] afterwards.
But today, what happens
when black women do
decide to all sit out one day?
If we don't show up.
Like, how far would we be--
how far would women be?
Even though we usually get
the brunt of, oh, my god,
the Black Lives Matter
people are protesting.
They should like,
stop stopping traffic.
Meanwhile not
realizing that, like,
your kids are
benefiting from the fact
that these people
are stopping traffic.
So I mean, I think it's
really important for people
to acknowledge that.
It's the fact that
black Americans do not
get enough credit for the amount
of work that they've put on--
I was born in
Nigeria, so I'm also
an immigrant in that I didn't
come here until I was nine.
And Africans come here
and get really successful,
but we also have to
acknowledge the reason we're
able to do that is
because when we come here,
all the work that black
Americans have done
allow us to come here and
then become doctors in three
years and four years, and
then be able to be, like,
in the 10%, which is amazing.
So I just wanted to take
this moment to say, like,
black Americans, y'all
are super heroes.
You don't get told that enough.
And history doesn't give you
enough credit, but it should.
PAOLA MENDOZA: And
to that point--
and this is something that I'd
like to say publicly as often
as I can--
that the Women's March
was as successful
as it was because we were
literally on the backs of Black
Lives Matter.
Black Lives Matter had been
training the American people
for two, three years previous
to the women's movement
to go out to the streets, to
protest, to shut things down.
And it was when
the perfect event
of Donald Trump and
everything that he
had done to women and an
event was posted on Facebook
that we had just the
perfect energy, synergy,
whatever you want to call
it, to get millions of people
out to the street.
But I don't think that we would
have had that had Black Lives
Matter not been happening for
three years previous to that.
And also what you're
talking about I
think at the end of
the day is something
that is organizing 101.
When we put the most
marginalized people
at the center of the movement,
and we work towards them,
and we realize that our freedom
is bound to their freedom,
that's the work that
needs to get done.
So when we're here
in this space,
and we're talking about race,
the reason race is important
and the reason why we
need to be uncomfortable
and the reason why we need to
have these daring discussions
is because when we have them, we
will all start to become free.
We will all get closer to that
place that we're striving for.
And so I think that's why Google
is having this conversation,
because they are
obviously-- you all
are obviously at the forefront
of where we need to go.
And that is why
it's important to,
whether if you're white, if
you're black, if you're Latino,
if you're undocumented, if
you're gay, if you're straight,
if you're disabled,
whatever it is--
that is the importance and
the power of the conversation.
ROLAND MARTIN: So but how are we
dealing with intersectionality?
EDDIE HUANG: I'm sorry.
I really want to respond to
what she said, because I really
understand your frustration.
And you don't need
me to say it, but I
think it's very, very fair
that some people sat out
the Women's March.
Because it's like the
sword in the stone,
do you know what I mean?
It's like, you know,
Black Lives Matter
have been pulling on
this sword in the stone,
doing all the work
pushing it forward,
trying to open America's eyes.
And a lot of people
are just like, why
are you saying-- why are we
talking about Black Lives
Matter?
Treating it almost
like a nuisance,
do you know what I mean?
Treating Colin
Kaepernick like he
was a nuisance, when
in fact that man
sacrificed his career to make
a statement and awaken America.
And it has to be frustrating
from a black perspective
to see that when white
women were attacked,
that then the sword was
taken out of the stone.
ROLAND MARTIN: That's called
being black in America.
No, I mean, that's the reality.
EDDIE HUANG: Even a China man
can understand that, though.
ROLAND MARTIN: We're
just like, you know.
EDDIE HUANG: I'd like
to say this, too--
ROLAND MARTIN: You got
the New York Giants owner
in today's newspaper talking
about we got all these letters
from Giants fans saying we're
going to boycott if you sign
Kaepernick, but they
didn't say a damn thing
when they had a
kicker who was beating
the hell out of his wife.
EDDIE HUANG: Yeah.
And the other thing, too, is I
would say, is, like, I totally
get the frustration,
but sometimes I
feel like, as a minority
or a person of color,
however everyone's supposed
to be identified these days,
it's like unfortunately,
we may not have
the privilege of sitting out.
ROLAND MARTIN: No, no, no.
EDDIE HUANG: [INAUDIBLE],,
you know what I mean?
ROLAND MARTIN: Here's how
I see her sitting out.
It's sort of like if we're
in a tug of war, it's like--
EDDIE HUANG: You and Rick
Mahorn pull the chair out.
ROLAND MARTIN: No, it's like--
I'm going to take a rest.
[INAUDIBLE]
LUVVIE AJAYI: That's it.
That's it.
ROLAND MARTIN: No.
Basically, we're
like, in a tug of war,
I'm going to take a breather.
[INAUDIBLE]
LUVVIE AJAYI: That's it.
ROLAND MARTIN: I'm
going to step out.
And I'm going to get back in.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I'm gonna get back
in, but give me five minutes.
ROLAND MARTIN: [INAUDIBLE]
LUVVIE AJAYI: Your turn.
ROLAND MARTIN: But I want
to go to Vint, though,
because I want to do this
intersectionality piece,
because it's
interesting when you
talk about this intersection
of different issues.
I think about-- and again,
I brought the 14th Amendment
again, equal protection clause.
The Supreme Court, when they
decided same sex marriage was
based upon that, what was
interesting is BYP100 had done
a shout out where
they said, look, OK,
y'all get same sex marriage.
That ain't what we
concerned about.
And it was interesting
because I had
black gay folks who
were saying, that
ain't number one on our list.
And I've had to deal with
African-Americans, same
you're talking Jose
Antonio Vargas, Asians,
Latinos, who are gay, who are in
this movement saying, hold it.
How we all gay, but then we're
still fighting marginalization
in the LGBT movement-- in
the equality movement that
practices inequality?
So as we begin to
move forward, I
think we're going to see
even more of those battles
where all of a
sudden it's not as
clear as black,
Asian, Latino, women.
Now it's going to
be things crossing.
VINT CERF: Look, there are
dozens, if not more, categories
in which everyone fits.
And a lot of those categories
will put you into minority.
And so it seems to
me absolutely clear
that everything that you were
saying with regard to people
of color and your sense of
oppression and unfairness
will show up in all of those
other instances as well.
The net result of all
that is that if we've
got to get Americans to
understand and believe
that no one is free
until we all are.
EDDIE HUANG: Yes.
LUVVIE AJAYI: That's actually--
EDDIE HUANG: The man
invented the internet.
LUVVIE AJAYI: That's a
mantra the BYP100 says.
Like, none of us are free
until we're all free.
And understanding what you
said, like our freedom is bound
to somebody else's
freedom, is what
will make you get out
of bed in the morning
when it doesn't have
anything to do with you.
Right?
But the thing is, like, most
Americans don't get out of bed
until it has something
to do with them.
They're not getting out to march
until, oh, he said something
about white women.
Now I have to--
where were you for
the last two years?
So it's a matter of
us seeing ourselves
in other people's
struggles and understand
that if that person has a
harder time living a free life,
I will, too, in some way.
It's going to show up
in some way in my life.
And that means their
struggle is my struggle.
That means their fight
has to be my fight.
Until we do that,
nothing's going to happen.
VINT CERF: That's right.
ROLAND MARTIN: About five
to eight more minutes
until our panel is going to go
to questions from the audience,
and so please let me know--
VINT CERF: Mr. Moderator?
ROLAND MARTIN:
Hold on one second.
Doing some housekeeping.
So let me know when the
questions are up here.
OK?
Go right ahead.
VINT CERF: So I
was going to make
one other psychological
observation.
People see behaviors
that they don't like.
And they'll say,
I don't like them,
you know, for whatever reason.
But what they don't do is what
you were suggesting earlier,
which is to dig deeper
to find out what is
the reason for that behavior?
What are the incentives
that drive that behavior?
And until we understand
what the incentives are,
we won't be able to
change the behavior.
Because just complaining
about it doesn't work.
You have to figure out how
to change the incentives.
And that's probably the
most fundamental question
that we have to wrestle with.
How do we change the
incentives for the behaviors
that we don't like?
ROLAND MARTIN: And
when we say incentives,
that means, look, how many
folks have been to Washington DC
in a visit or been
by the White House?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Lately?
VINT CERF: Well,
I live there, so--
ROLAND MARTIN: In
your whole life.
In your whole life.
Yes.
Thank you.
VINT CERF: Thank you.
Right.
Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: Now I'm
gonna ask this question.
There's only one federal
agency that shares
a lawn with the White House.
They can literally play
flag football on the lawn.
Which agency?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Treasury.
VINT CERF: No, it's--
ROLAND MARTIN: Treasury.
VINT CERF: Treasury.
Oh, that's right.
Yeah.
ROLAND MARTIN: To understand
America, power, money.
Money, power.
That's the only one that shares
a lawn with the White House.
You could literally go 100 steps
out the side of the Treasury
Department, you'll be in the
East Wing of the White House.
So we talk about
incentives, Vint.
I think about Al Newhart, when
he was the CEO of Gannett,
the founder of USA Today.
He said, here's a guy,
grew up in South Dakota.
Didn't see many black people.
But he said, we're going
to be the leading company
when it comes to diversity.
And he then said, I'm going
to attach our diversity
goal to your bonuses.
And then he said, if
you don't like it,
you can leave the company.
And there were people who left.
And he said, see ya,
because they wouldn't do it.
And so when Gannett became
the leader in the industry
for diversity, it caused
[INAUDIBLE] to go,
then we better get
our act together.
It literally caused
a ripple effect.
The entire media industry
said, we'd better go start
recruiting some folks,
because Gannett's
going to get all of the
great minority talent.
That changed the game.
VINT CERF: Interesting.
ROLAND MARTIN: The
president of FX, same thing.
They did a study in
FX network, and he
said, how is it that
88%, or whatever,
of our movies, our show
runners, are white males?
And he sent a single
email out saying
this should not be the case.
Six months later, it was
flipped to nearly half
of their shows were
people of color.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I mean, look at--
ROLAND MARTIN: But
that was a leader.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Look what
"Scandal" did for television.
ROLAND MARTIN: That
was leadership.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I mean,
when "Scandal" started,
the last black lead for a
prime time show or drama
was Diahann Caroll in 1974.
So when "Scandal" became
successful, literally all
the TV networks was
like, oh, it can
be profitable for a black
woman to lead a show.
Then it actually became a
thing that all the networks
were doing.
It is the money that's tied to
it and chained to incentives.
So like now, in publishing.
For a long time, they were
like, oh, black people don't
read books, so we're not
going to really give you guys
a lot of book deals.
And they started
giving us book deals,
and they realized
we can hit "New York
Times" best seller list.
Oh, somebody else can
get a book deal now.
It's always tied to the money.
Always.
ROLAND MARTIN: Questions.
Y'all ready?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Was
that a mic drop?
Was that a mic drop?
ROLAND MARTIN: I said, power
and money, money and power.
All right.
Let's role.
Really?
Really, you don't
have questions?
All right.
Who got a question?
VINT CERF: Here we go.
We can see it here.
ROLAND MARTIN: OK,
we've got a microphone.
Man, come on.
Who got a question?
Really?
Nobody here has a question?
VINT CERF: Wait, no.
It's right-- hey.
ROLAND MARTIN: I've got him.
VINT CERF: We've got
the question here.
ROLAND MARTIN: Here we go.
Microphone works.
Step on up in light.
Come on.
It's going to be like the
old Phil Donahue show.
EDDIE HUANG: No, Roland, we
got a-- we got a question--
ROLAND MARTIN: Let me explain
to you who Phil Donahue is.
OK.
You know who Phil Donahue is.
I see the grey hair.
Yes, indeed.
What's your name?
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: My name
is Jason, and you
said that it's hard
to challenge someone,
just call them a racist.
So having these conversations
maybe more around,
as Eddie suggested, around a
specific reaction somebody had
or a thing they said.
What are some good ideas
for how to do that?
I've got a big family.
I need to do a lot of education.
ROLAND MARTIN: Oh.
He's trying to survive
Thanksgiving and Christmas.
All right.
Who wants to take that?
LUVVIE AJAYI: I've had
that question sent to me
a lot of times, because I've
challenged my white readers
to not be silent in the face
of just problematic things
happening in their--
like, if you're
silent as it's happening,
you're giving it air.
So my suggestion is to
just really point it out.
So you're at dinner,
and let's say
your uncle makes
that racist joke.
You should be like, hey,
yeah, that's not OK.
Simply even saying, that's
not OK is better than you
just being like,
oh, here he goes.
Because you let him know
that when you're in the room,
he has less space for that.
He will do it less in your
presence at the minimum,
if nothing else.
Start there.
ROLAND MARTIN: True.
Eddie?
EDDIE HUANG: Yeah, you
know, when I was younger,
I used to turn in these essays.
They were like fiery,
angry, analytical essays.
And my teacher-- I had a
professor, Doctor Jones,
ask me-- she said, why is it
that you use this language?
Why is it that you just beat
the reader over the head
over and over?
And I said, because I'm right.
And she said, OK, fair.
I agree with you.
ROLAND MARTIN: Damn.
You too, huh?
EDDIE HUANG: Yeah.
And she said, I agree with
you that you're right.
You have proven it over the
course of these paragraphs.
But the purpose of writing is
to communicate and to persuade.
And she says, you should be
a more results-based writer.
And at first, I was upset.
I didn't accept it.
But over time, I
realized, just being
right does not give you license
to attack people with language.
Also being right, you
don't get a medal for that.
You need the results.
You need people to
open their eyes.
The purpose is to
convey your feelings
and for them to understand you.
And I've noticed, at least
in my own personal life,
the more patient and
generous and humble
I am in front of someone
that may have said something
that I consider racist,
I get more when I give.
And it's such a
hard thing to do.
It's really hard.
LUVVIE AJAYI: That
is labor intensive.
ROLAND MARTIN: But
it's also based--
it's also based upon
really the situation.
Here is the way you are.
EDDIE HUANG: I mean,
I interviewed a guy
from the alt right, like, in a
DC episode of "Huang's World."
ROLAND MARTIN:
White nationalists.
That's what I call them.
I don't call it the alt right.
EDDIE HUANG: He was the
director founder of AmRen.
And you know, from the
beginning, I could have got hot
and argued with him.
I probably should have
choked him, you know?
But I just kept, at
least in my mind, giving.
ROLAND MARTIN: Right.
EDDIE HUANG: And giving.
And then you know what?
That fool walked
himself into a hole.
ROLAND MARTIN: Oh, every time.
EDDIE HUANG: Yeah.
ROLAND MARTIN: So
they're not smart.
No, they're not.
EDDIE HUANG: They're
also hateful.
ROLAND MARTIN: I
had Richard Spencer
for 32 minutes on my show.
It was supposed to
be eight minutes.
LUVVIE AJAYI: You didn't
punch him in the face,
like everybody else?
ROLAND MARTIN: I said, I won't
beat his ass for about 10
more minutes.
Then another 10 minutes.
And again, he looked
crazy at the end.
But I do believe
the moment matters.
Like, I don't like it
when I'm in a first class,
like I've got
Texas A&M stuff on.
They say, you play football?
Hell no.
Did you?
No.
Because really, I
want you to ask first,
is that your-- is that
where you went to school?
Don't assume I played
ball or I coach there.
And so depending on how I
feel, I might be nice about it,
and say, no.
Or I might be very dismissive.
Hell, no.
All depends on the mood I'm in.
What's your question?
AUDIENCE: So I was--
ROLAND MARTIN: I've got the mic.
We're good.
Put your hands in your pocket.
AUDIENCE: I'm Christina,
and I recently-- well,
first of all, thanks
for being here
and thanks for this
discussion and everything.
I'm really glad that I work at
a company where this is valued.
I recently read a book
called "Homegoing,"
and it's one of the best
books I've read ever,
so if you haven't
read it, you should.
And it talks about, for
anybody who hasn't read it,
the story of two
different family--
one family, two sisters.
One follows, like, her lineage
for the last 400 years,
going from the
Gold Coast in Ghana
to the United States
and everything.
You know, basically
living in slavery
and then after slavery,
blah, blah, blah, blah.
And it was just a
heartbreaking book to read.
And while reading
it, it was just,
like, there's black people
just don't even have a--
you know, they didn't
have a chance ever.
You know, like, with
that kind of history,
they're so far behind.
There was so much
institutional baggage.
It just felt very heartbreaking.
Fast forward to-- well, not
fast forward, but the same time,
I lived in Clinton
Hill, Brooklyn.
You know, 90% voted
against Trump,
and very democratic, very
open liberal community.
And yet you look at your
schools in my neighborhood,
and they are, frankly, they're
sort of segregated, you know?
PAOLA MENDOZA: They
are segregated.
New York City has the
most segregated schools
in the country, and more so
than the Civil Rights Movement
during the '60s.
AUDIENCE: And the rates of
incarceration, you know.
So you have this
sort of dissonance
that I'm so uncomfortable
with, and I don't really
know what to do with it.
But I just thought--
I don't really have a question.
I'm just like--
ROLAND MARTIN: Oh, no.
We got it.
AUDIENCE: --and schools, and
where are we and is there hope?
VINT CERF: Pointing
out the dissonance
is exactly the
right thing to do.
I think it's an extremely
helpful thing to do.
And now we all have homework
to go read that book.
ROLAND MARTIN: But it's also
not accepting the silly notion
that it's a Democratic
or Republican thing.
And that's the problem.
So when-- what's
the fool on CNN?
LUVVIE AJAYI: Which one?
ROLAND MARTIN: I know.
There's a lot of them.
Jeffrey Lord.
So when Jeffrey Lord's
running his mouth,
and he's talking about, oh,
the Democrats carry the KKK.
And the problem I have is
that too many people on CNN
have no understanding
of history,
because it's very easy to
shut Jeffrey Lord down.
You simply say, Jeffrey
Lord, which president
left the white lily
movement in the 1930s?
And he will look at
you like you're crazy.
He will say Herbert Hoover.
He was a Republican.
See?
So what happens is
a long it becomes,
oh, if you're Republican,
you hate minorities,
and if you're a Democrat,
you love minorities,
you lose sight of the fact that
our schools come down to money.
Democrats like money.
Republicans like money.
They like money in their
own school districts.
And so that's, I
think, where we fail.
This is not to
change these systems.
It's not a Democrat
or Republican thing.
It's a human thing.
Democrats can be just
as idiotic and stupid
when it comes to allocation
of resources as Republicans.
In many cases, Republicans
have been actually
more supportive of historically
black colleges and universities
in the White House
than the Democrats.
So again, don't fault
for the political trap.
The question is where do
you stand on the issue,
regardless of your party?
PAOLA MENDOZA: And
also, I think, just
to take it a step further
with regards to liberal,
and I'll be fast since
we have someone else.
There's a school.
I also live in that
area, in Fort Greene.
A friend of mine, she sent
her child to a charter school
from all Fort Greene,
Clinton Hill area.
And the parents actually
advocated for the principal
to take away African-American
History Month.
EDDIE HUANG: What?
PAOLA MENDOZA:
These are liberals.
EDDIE HUANG: What
school is this?
PAOLA MENDOZA: It's
somewhere downtown.
I don't know where.
It's an elementary school.
ROLAND MARTIN: Eddie's
looking for it.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Exactly.
That was my reaction.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Eddie's like, what?
Show me the school.
He going right now.
PAOLA MENDOZA: It's liberals,
educated, predominantly white
community, and they talk to
a black principal to say,
please take away
African-American History Month,
because that's just
saying to our children
that we're different.
And we're not all different.
We're equal.
Right?
So that is also--
not understanding the
importance and the purpose
and the point of
saying, actually, we're
not all the same.
We are different, and there's
beauty in differences,
and that is the important thing.
Not to make us all one.
So I think to your point
and to Roland's point,
it doesn't matter
if you're a Democrat
or Republican or a
liberal, it's really
how you're analyzing
and seeing the world
and checking inside to say,
I don't understand this,
and I don't understand this,
like you're saying, and why?
What can I do?
Who do I talk to?
Who do I expose myself
to and my children
to to actually understand why
African-American history is
important.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Also, it's
important for white liberals
not to feel like just
because they're liberal,
they're doing the work.
Like the fact that a whole
neighborhood community that
considers themselves liberal
can tell a principal take Black
History Month away,
it comes to the idea
that, first of all, people
always think bad guy, good guy,
right?
I'm liberal.
I'm good.
No.
You're not good.
You're part of this
amazing system that is
just-- you're embedded in it.
And you just being like, I'm
liberal, is not the solution.
you have to do more
than just be liberal.
ROLAND MARTIN: If you read
Dr. King's book, "Chaos
or Community?
Where do We Go From Here,"
which is his worst selling book,
written in '67, he
said in the book,
it didn't cost America much
to allow us to go in a hotel,
it didn't cost America much to
allow us to go in the parks,
didn't cost America
much to allow
us to eat in the restaurants.
He said, the real
question now is
what will America write that
big check to fix the problem.
And he said even our
white allies will not
be with us because they
believe you've gotten enough.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yup.
ROLAND MARTIN: So there's
point is, that's why--
just like there are
some black people
I am not riding with,
because they're crazy.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: So
the issues goes
to where do you stand
on stuff, as opposed
to what do you look like and
what's your party affiliation.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Right.
ROLAND MARTIN:
What's your question?
Put your hand down.
I got you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm Samera,
an Iranian-American woman.
So I think it's a follow
up to your question, is,
what is that next?
I think it's a cultural thing,
being born and raised here,
and being a terrorist growing
up until the current day,
and the immigration
law and all that.
I think it was always
like, don't say anything,
from your parents.
It's something culturally
ingrained, like don't push,
don't push the boundaries.
Don't get yourself in trouble.
Now being a mother
of two kids, I'm
like, no, we need to
push the boundary.
I just don't know what that is.
Because I've always
been told to step back.
ROLAND MARTIN: Good one.
Who wants it?
LUVVIE AJAYI: You've
always been told
to step back because you
were not in the best position
to push forward.
So the people who are in the
good position to push forward
should be the ones
pushing forward for you.
Because you, right
now, pushing forward
is a threat to you
and your livelihood.
Meanwhile, white men are sitting
up here not doing anything.
They should be pushing
forward for you.
So I mean, your
existence is resistance,
basically at this point.
EDDIE HUANG: I
understand what you're
saying, that people
in power should
be doing their jobs
as our representatives
and pushing things forward.
But at least, in
my experience, I've
noticed that no one's going
to do anything for you
but yourself, you know.
And I come from my a community,
Taiwanese, Chinese-Americans,
we're also told just be
quiet, look at your feet
when you're walking down the
street, don't cause no trouble.
I mean, every single
movie has an Asian person
with the same line, I
don't want no trouble.
You know what I mean?
That's been our
community's standard line
for, like, 30 years.
I don't want no trouble.
Or you break you buy.
We got a few lines,
that's really it.
But you know--
VINT CERF: What
about that other one.
Go ahead, make my day.
EDDIE HUANG: I feel
sorry for your mother.
But no, like, those
are our three lines,
very known for delivering
those, in all manner
of cultural product.
ROLAND MARTIN: Hey,
we used to get killed
before the credits finished.
I understand that.
I mean, the credits
weren't done.
Damn, the brother's
already dead.
OK.
EDDIE HUANG: We're like,
we don't want no trouble.
LUVVIE AJAYI: But you made
it through a movie though.
EDDIE HUANG: We made
it through the movie.
ROLAND MARTIN: At
least y'all made it.
VINT CERF: I
actually wanted want
to counter your observation
that no one will do anything
unless you do it for yourself.
EDDIE HUANG: OK, sure.
VINT CERF: That's not true.
EDDIE HUANG: OK.
I'm gonna finish this point.
VINT CERF: All right.
EDDIE HUANG: You
invented the internet,
so you can shut me
down whenever you want.
I would just say,
though, that I actually--
VINT CERF: If you want your
email to continue working.
EDDIE HUANG: So
I was just saying
that I didn't see anyone else
in my community speaking up,
and I was like, I'm
going to try to do this
at least for myself, for my
family, and for my brothers,
and it goes on, and on, and on.
And it's incredible the power
that one person has if you just
set your mind to it.
I feel like you should
engage in and do something.
ROLAND MARTIN: Question.
"There have been
reports today--"
VINT CERF: Wait a
minute, Mr. Moderator--
ROLAND MARTIN: I know.
I've got five minutes.
I got to get to this question
before they cuss me out,
these tweets.
"There have been
reports today, Google
thinks is too expensive
and labor intensive
to investigate the DOJ
claims that we systematically
underpay women.
If this is true,
how can we advocate
that, at least
within the company,
to ensure that we do pay our
women and minorities equally?"
VINT CERF: Point of order.
EDDIE HUANG: I don't
think that's too
expensive for Google.
ROLAND MARTIN: Oh,
that's for Vint.
That was for Vint.
VINT CERF: Point of order.
It's not the DOJ.
It's the Department
of Labor that
is asking for the statistics.
And apparently, we have
given them an enormous amount
of statistical information.
We even have data that shows
that when we hire women,
they get higher pay raises
than the men do in order
to adjust for the
fact that they've
been historically underpaid.
So there's a lot of
evidence that Google
has done a great deal to
even out these things.
It's built in now to our
algorithms for raises
and things like that.
It's now algorithmically built.
EDDIE HUANG: You've got a
snitch in your company, though.
[LAUGHING]
ROLAND MARTIN: Paola, go ahead.
[INAUDIBLE] out here snitching.
PAOLA MENDOZA: I think-- this
is what I like to advocate,
and this is what I do
on my own personal life.
I think we just need to
share how much we make.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Word.
PAOLA MENDOZA: Women,
you just need to go up,
and you need to
ask your coworker,
hey, how much do you make?
This is what I make.
I'm just saying.
We as women and as
people of color,
need to share
information because when
we have information, we
can then empower ourselves
from a place of knowledge.
And it's as simple as that.
Break down that barrier
and ask the question.
And men, be up front
with your coworker.
And you can go up to her,
him, too, and say, hey,
I make this amount of money.
How much do you make?
EDDIE HUANG: I would pull up
to the club with my tax return,
if that was socially acceptable.
You feel me?
ROLAND MARTIN: Next question.
"I recently had a
conversation with a friend who
insisted racism, sexism is no
longer a problem in America,
that America is the least
racist country in the world."
Parentheses, "It was a baffling
and frustrating conversation,
no doubt.
Does the panel have
suggestions for how
to get people to rethink
this misconception?"
One person, who
wants to take it?
LUVVIE AJAYI: I'd probably
stop being friends with them,
because I'm like you just so
out of-- just out of touch.
Just, I can't.
I mean, where do you go?
So when you're having a
discussion with somebody,
the point is to have
this middle ground.
But when you're over here,
and the person's over here,
how do you come to
the middle with that?
VINT CERF: That's what
you've been trying to do.
And both of you have said
that you're trying to find--
the trick was to get away
from the racist discussion
and get to something
more specific.
Because, in fact,
whatever it was
might not actually have
been a racist issue at all,
it might have been
something else.
But finding something concrete.
LUVVIE AJAYI: But this person
said it's no longer a problem.
This person said racism
and sexism is no longer
a problem in America,
and that America
is the least racist country.
How do you talk to that person?
EDDIE HUANG: When someone is
like that out to lunch, out
to sea, I'm just like, please
tell me how you got here.
Just tell me more.
Like we said, I just
want to hear more.
VINT CERF: Just ask--
ROLAND MARTIN: I think
in that situation,
no matter how stupid
or crazy they are,
you still force them to
say, OK, well, let's talk
about the study that
showed that if you have
a black sounding name, you have
50% less likelihood of getting
a return phone call for a
job than if you were white,
when it is the
exact same resume.
LUVVIE AJAYI: They
will find excuses.
ROLAND MARTIN: No, but
here's the deal though.
In my experience, in
hitting people every day
with questions, you begin to hit
folks with specific questions
and data, it's hard to ignore.
The problem, I
think, in that case,
is when you have
general conversation.
When you hit them
with specifics,
it's a little harder
for them to wiggle out
because they have to justify how
that forms with their opinion.
Question.
AUDIENCE: On the
panel there, they
talked about how there's like
two ends of the spectrum,
right?
You have one person that
could be called a racist,
and then another
person who disagrees.
And then the meat of
the issue gets lost.
When I think about a
lot of these things,
there's a lot of facts
that are hitting history.
And as you stood on the stage,
and you were reading out
lots of facts, I
was just like, wow,
because not a lot
of people know that.
ROLAND MARTIN: Because
they didn't read.
AUDIENCE: They
didn't read, and I
didn't grow up in this country.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Nigeria?
AUDIENCE: Like Luvvie--
LUVVIE AJAYI: I knew you
were a Nigeria man, yes.
VINT CERF: You recognized that.
LUVVIE AJAYI: I saw my people.
AUDIENCE: I came to the USA.
I took an African-American
culture class,
and I was just amazed at a lot
of things that are in history,
but again, are lost
to a lot of people.
ROLAND MARTIN: There's
history, and there's his-story.
Two different meanings.
True.
And I know the writer
Ta-Nesisi Coates,
and he wrote that
magnificent essay.
And again, so much facts in
there that not a lot of people
know.
So how do you get those
facts out there to people?
Because at the end of the
day, we're all human beings.
And that's what
we're trying to do.
Because you can't
force people to love.
VINT CERF: I have an
unfortunate observation
to make about the
American culture.
ROLAND MARTIN: Thank you.
Go, go.
We got two minutes.
VINT CERF: The American
culture tends to have amnesia.
If you visit in Europe, there
will be casual conversation
in which the years 1400
and 1066 and 1622 and 1648
are regularly mentioned
as if they were yesterday.
In America, you can't remember
what happened two weeks ago.
And so we have cultural, really
serious cultural problems
remembering facts and history.
And I don't know
how to fix that.
ROLAND MARTIN: Well,
part of the problem
is that we have not actually
had real American history
in our schools.
That's why I say history
and his-story, that's real.
And so there's so
many things that
are actually being left out.
And so for me, I use my
media platforms to do it,
every single day, in terms
of I got #rolandbookclub.
So people ask me, dude, how
you know all this other stuff?
These are all the
books that I've read.
Then they're like, OK,
man, I understand now.
And so, we also have to
make history accessible
and explain it in a way--
you got to remember,
newspapers, historically,
have taught us
write on a fifth grade level.
It may sound crazy.
But you write on a
fifth grade level.
And so to understand, and
literally, I was on the radio
today, and they were trying
to talk about economics,
and I said, OK, let me
just walk you through.
1619 to 1863, 244
years of slavery.
Two years of the war,
then you had, of course,
end of the war, 1865 to 1877,
12 years of Reconstruction.
Great Compromises of
1877 starts Jim Crow.
That goes through almost 1970.
If you use the death of
King, April 4th, '68,
then let's say
another two years,
so if you say 1970
is the marker where
black folks were technically
fully free Americans, that's
only 47.
Only 47 years.
When people hear that,
they go, whoa, hold on.
That's it?
Then you say yes, the first
wave of black and blue corporate
America happened
in the early '70s.
The first African-Americans
on Wall Street,
in terms of Morgan
Stanley, those companies.
Then the first African-Americans
in major Ivy League
institutions.
Now all of the sudden--
then I say, I'll
be 49 in November.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Wow.
ROLAND MARTIN: Which means
I was born into an America
where I was not fully free.
Which means-- I
don't have any kids--
my nieces and nephews
are the first generation
of African-Americans born
technically fully free.
Now people go, damn.
Because they think
slavery, 1863, and totally
ignore the fact
that we literally
were frozen out of
economic systems
through the 1960s to 1970.
But again, it's getting people
to break it down that way.
Then they go, whoa,
as opposed to just,
oh, slavery ended at this time.
Because people really,
they just don't know.
Even a whole lot of black
people have no idea, no clue.
EDDIE HUANG: You
mentioned Dr. King.
You asked the question about--
you asked the question about
we have all these facts,
yet it seems like people don't
want to listen or give credence
to these facts.
And I think Dr. King's works,
it really tells you the most
and gives you the blueprint.
"Letter from Birmingham
Jail" is probably
the most analytical essay
that Dr. King wrote.
It breaks things down
systematically with facts,
and it's written
to intellectuals.
But his most powerful--
ROLAND MARTIN:
Actually, it was written
to white pastors in Birmingham.
EDDIE HUANG: Yes,
intellectuals, yes.
So his most powerful
speech, though,
and the most persuasive speech,
undeniably, is I Have a Dream.
And that is a persuasive speech.
And I think that all of
us have to acknowledge,
it's not just enough
to be right if we
want the result that we desire.
We have to be persuasive.
ROLAND MARTIN: But don't
just read the bottom one
third of the speech.
First all, it was never even
called "I Have a Dream" speech.
It was called
"Normalcy No More."
EDDIE HUANG: I understand this.
But you're talking to me
like I don't know the facts--
ROLAND MARTIN: No, no, no.
I'm saying it to other
folks in the room.
Here's why.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Come
on, knowledge.
ROLAND MARTIN:
Because every year,
we replay the King's speech, and
we replay the "I Have a Dream"
part.
We don't talk about
the top two thirds,
where he talked about police
brutality, economic inequality,
bank of injustice, because
"I Have a Dream" part
is all nice and feely.
EDDIE HUANG: What does
that tell you, Roland?
LUVVIE AJAYI: It makes him
the patron saint of good times
and nonviolence.
ROLAND MARTIN: Right.
LUVVIE AJAYI: That's
what that makes him.
ROLAND MARTIN: We turned
King into a bobblehead--
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: As opposed
to a radical revolutionary
that he was.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Exactly.
ROLAND MARTIN: So the
challenge to anybody
in the room is, don't leave here
just reading the bottom part,
start from the
beginning, and then go,
whoa, dude was slaying
folks, and not holding hands.
EDDIE HUANG: Of course, but
do you think that he would be
as productive and persuasive--
LUVVIE AJAYI: And assassinated--
EDDIE HUANG: --and
create all the progress
that he did if he
was not smart enough
to be persuasive as well?
ROLAND MARTIN: No,
he was persuasive.
EDDIE HUANG: He was a genius.
ROLAND MARTIN: He was a
radical revolutionary.
EDDIE HUANG: He did it all.
He was a five tool player,
like persuasive and analytical.
And you can't just keep
telling people read the facts,
read this, read this.
They're not-- a lot of
people aren't going to.
You have to persuade them.
They need sugar
with the medicine.
ROLAND MARTIN: But what
we've done, though, is--
this is why I disagree
with you, Eddie.
What we've done is,
we've only given America
the I Have a Dream part, because
that's the hand-holding part.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Yes.
ROLAND MARTIN: See,
the top, that's
the equivalent of
listening to a sermon,
and you cheering, but you
skipped the scripture.
EDDIE HUANG: I'm not telling
you to skip the rest,
I'm telling you to
Trojan horse people.
ROLAND MARTIN: But I want
them to read the whole thing.
EDDIE HUANG: You
ever gone fishing
without something on the hook?
ROLAND MARTIN: I hate fishing.
Damn it, I'm going
to the supermarket
to buy some catfish.
Blend, what's up?
AUDIENCE: My name is Tsvi,
and I was curious what the--
ROLAND MARTIN: Spell that.
AUDIENCE: T-S-V-I.
ROLAND MARTIN: I would
have never got that.
EDDIE HUANG: I've seen
your graffiti around town.
AUDIENCE: Oh, yeah,
that's my tag.
So my question is about protests
on college campuses being
shut down.
Sorry, speakers being shut
down because of protests.
Not just like people asking
good questions at the end,
or making a little
noise at the beginning,
but then letting
the person speak.
I'm talking about fully
shutting down speakers
like at Middlebury or Berkeley.
And I was just curious
what, you know--
I understand it's a very
nuanced, complicated issue.
But I was curious--
VINT CERF: It's not
complicated at all.
AUDIENCE: Thanks a lot.
VINT CERF: This is not
complicated at all.
This is an incredible
erosion of what
should be a serious freedom
of speech on the campuses.
I think it's outrageous
that students do that,
because the whole key
here, and the thing
we've been talking
about all this session
is about the conversations that
we have to have on tough topics
where there's real
serious disagreement.
And hearing the other side is
an important part of all that.
So I think it's outrageous
that the campuses have
been forced to do this.
ROLAND MARTIN: Stupid and
asinine, that's what it is.
No, it is.
Because what happens when
someone wants to shut down
a speaker you like?
PAOLA MENDOZA: Which
is happening right now
with Linda Sarsour.
So Linda Sarsour is the
commencement speaker at CUNY,
and the right wing has
taken it up to try and shut
her down because
she's a Muslim woman,
and they claim a lot of things.
And I know Linda
personally very well,
that are completely not true.
So there are protests.
There's an online
campaign against her.
And that is someone
that we want speaking.
And that is someone that I
believe in what she's saying.
So I agree that it's not
a difficult question.
Speakers should be
allowed to speak.
ROLAND MARTIN: Final comment.
The one thing you want
people leaving here with,
moving forward.
30 seconds, go.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Just
challenge your own ideas,
and also read beyond the
"I Have a Dream" speech.
I'm really glad you
actually brought that up.
Because MLK Day comes
and everyone share's
the exact same quotes, of
him being this pacifist,
like yeah, we just
all need to unite.
No, like, before he
even got to that dude,
and even as his
politics went further,
he got even more radical.
So for all the
historical figures,
you hear about Rosa Parks
sitting on the bus, read deeper
about these same bobbleheads
that you keep seeing
in social media as buttons.
And realize what they
were saying back then,
because I feel like
there's something
we need to learn from them.
There's a lot of things.
PAOLA MENDOZA: I
want to challenge
everyone here and listening
to have a conversation that
makes your heart pound, that
makes your palms sweaty.
And do that and be OK in that
feeling of uncomfortability
and knowing that when you get
to the other side, whatever
that conversation is about,
that you're going to be OK.
And during that conversation--
and this is the most important
thing--
is that you have to
listen to understand, not
listen to be right.
And so, do that.
Do that this week.
Go have that conversation.
ROLAND MARTIN: Eddie?
EDDIE HUANG: Despite
all the stupidity
I see on an everyday basis,
I'm bullish on humanity,
and I do think that it's
going to get better.
ROLAND MARTIN: Vint?
VINT CERF: For the
Google people that
are here, take the
unconscious bias
test if you haven't already.
You will be just shocked to
discover that you have them.
You just don't know that yet.
ROLAND MARTIN: I created this
hashtag just playing around
called #teamwhipdatass.
LUVVIE AJAYI: Why?
Why is Roland like this?
ROLAND MARTIN: Well,
I did, team, whip--
W-H-I-P, dat-- D-A-T, A-S-S.
Y'all think I'm lying,
look it up.
Every day I wake up
ready to do battle.
Every day I have
breath, I believe
that I could flip
somebody on a given issue.
I don't why from a fight.
I don't back down from a battle.
I'll debate you.
It might be rough,
it might be soft.
It might easy.
It might be hand-holding.
Or I might have
to whoop your ass.
But that really is the
attitude that I have
because if people of conscience
take a day off and run
from the fight, then
ignorance always wins.
And the last thing
is, I'm never going
to let somebody else know
more information than I do,
so I'm going to read as much
as I can, so when they lie,
I can bust them
every single time.
Thanks a bunch, y'all.
Give it up for our panel.
EDDIE HUANG: Thanks, Roland.
[APPLAUSE]